Peace be upon you, with you, Omar Mohsen, you are writing
on Word. You have a lot left and the world is fine
with you, and suddenly the light cuts off. How do you act, God
willing? Here you are in this video. How can you
return the content that was lost from you or the writing
that you wrote on Word? Questions or any
program. The solution is that there is a need or  The feature is present
in all Microsoft programs. It is AutoSave,
which automatically saves every certain period of time, and
in most cases it is 10 minutes. Now, if you
lose a file,
follow the steps that follow. This is the first thing that will go to your
computer. If we say, “My computer,” then
it will open.  Drive C, which is the one in
Windows, is fine. After that, you go to User.
Of course, this is the color. This is Windows  App Data App Data
is mostly a hidden file, so you must show the hidden file so that if you do not have
this file, it will appear
quickly. How is the hidden file? I will not explain it. I mean, we will apply the steps.
Tools Folder Options View. Show. Okay.
The file will appear. I have it here. Double-click on it. After
that, I will go to the room and search for Microsoft.  If
we say this is this and then go to Word.
The first time I go to Word, notice at all that here
in the files that contain AutoSave, this is the
first method, and, God willing, God willing, this is the one in
which you will find your files present
in this place. Ok, on the way.  Again, yes,
I will go to the Word file. Now I will
go to the file. Notice that I have something called
Auto Recovery available here. Choose any one of
these and it will take me back to the length of the file I was
editing. And as they say, prevention is the best
cure. How can I make it do Auto?  A sword
every minute instead of 10 minutes, so that if there is a problem
and I forget to make a sword, at least the things
that will be removed from me will not be many. Ok, now you open your rose file, it will also
go to a
file. Of course, the virgin for Word or
versions will not make much difference. Files after that,
you will go to Options or Properties.
In Arabic, you will go further, Saif or Save, and I will find
myself in this beautiful place, Saif Autor, atone for information. You set the time period here, and in
most cases the less you make it is better, which is, for
example, every minute of medicine, and the place he is in
will be located. Where will you tell him that he wants to be in the
disk?  Top, for example, instead of this long path, you
will make
a frame that chooses Desktop,
and ok, I protected myself by doing, of course, ok, I
protected myself by
saying that it is running AutoSave every minute. If you notice the part below this, it tells me
that it is running AutoSave every minute, but of course these are
hours that cause me a problem.  The device is beeping because
every minute it auto-save for the content you
are writing. This was the method. If I helped you, do not
forget to like, comment, and subscribe,
because it really encourages me to complete for you
new content and see you in a new video. Also, a
little information like this. How did I write the text on the
paper?  Dot looks like
this, for example, if I took it in red, this is orange, and
you give me this, what do you think? It’s beautiful. Peace be upon you.